all right Jason's with us in Sacramento
hi Jason how are you good Dave how about
yourself better than I deserve what's up
so here's our scenario me and my wife
we're basically we're currently living
with my parents we've saved the total
last year's 52 thousand dollars and like
I said we're wonder if we should buy a
house in either here California or
out-of-state and we wanted your opinion
mm-hmm okay are you out of debt yes we
currently have been very blessed in that
situation we don't have any overhead we
just have our major bills their parents
who've just told us to work and save and
that's all we've done the last three
years okay how much do you have saved
52k good and that includes your
emergency fund er do you have a three to
six-month emergency fund in addition to
that I don't have it three to six I
started trying to figure out how to
learn to do it your way okay
well three to six months of expenses
would come out of your fifty-two and
then that wouldn't be the remaining
would be what you have for a down
payment
and what's your household income my wife
makes 33k gross I was currently making
about 55 to 60 but I just currently got
laid off I'm in sales so I'm currently
getting unemployment of $1,800 a month
okay well obviously you need to get
re-employed now what makes you think
about leaving the state what's the deal
well I guess the sort ran fair I see so
many just you know obviously cheaper
houses you know I don't not too much big
into this liberal state here also and
that's how they do things here but
wanted their opinion just like I said
I'm thinking about us yeah we keep her
homes is what basically it comes down to
from what I've been hurt told okay so
where would you maybe move well we're
thinking about the Midwest the southern
states just trying to I'm also wondering
should we wait and continue to save it
possible here's the thing my wife
obviously wants to spread her wings and
fly which she deserves and I want to
give that to her yeah I think it's time
to leave because now it's you're at a
point of
crossroads on your job and if you're
going to land a job in you know Des
Moines Iowa or whatever it's time to do
it while you're between jobs okay and
you know even if you go and you take
your money and you go rent for a little
while in that area you set some aside
for emergencies and then you continue to
build your down payment there and then
maybe buy six months or a year later
once you make that move but you've
probably been there long enough yeah I
mean I'm not saying I'm not saying you
have to leave California but you need to
make your decision where you're going to
live while you're jobless because you
don't want to do a job search there and
then turn around for months and go you
know I think we're moving to Des Moines
you know or whatever I made up a town
but I mean I don't care what town we're
talking about in come to Nashville we'd
love to have you but I mean you know
that kind of thing so the and yes
housing is cheaper almost anywhere than
California or Manhattan I mean that's
pretty well it you know I've some of the
most expensive real estate in America
today there's a few exceptions but not
many Sacramento is a wonderful town and
but but you know if you're ready to
leave then now would be the time to do
it you're at a crossroads it's a good
time and I think she I think your wife's
telling you it's time I think I heard
that in this between the lines here it's
probably time I think it's time